en espagne le gouvernement qui a
prolongé l'état dallaire jusqu'au 7 juin
est la cible de manifestations
quotidiennes l'épidémie de kobe de 19 et
responsables de 28 mille morts dans le
pays
barcelone et madrid sont les derniers à
grandes villes en europe à être presque
entièrement confinée le déconfinement en
espagne compte quatre phases et doit
s'étaler jusqu'en juillet mais les deux
grandes métropoles ne sont entrés que
dans la phase 0 avancé pour plus de
précisions retrouvait leslie singla à
barcelone liberté céline de ces
espagnols qui demandant des consignes en
plus rapide
des centaines de personnes participent à
des manifestations hebdomadaires à
madrid et à barcelone pour dénoncer la
gestion de la crise par le gouvernement
alors en espagne de déconfinement a
commencé mais il est très longue voire
trop lent pour ses habitants
les précautions prises par le
gouvernement et tonnes puisque les
chiffres de décès et de contagion
restent stables depuis plusieurs
semaines dans les hôpitaux
la situation est sous contrôle on parle
ici d'un véritable contraste avec les
voisins européens alors le gouvernement
espagnol concrètement a mis en place
quatre phases dans son plan de
déconfinement une grande partie du pays
se trouve désormais en phase une source
barcelone et madrid les plus grandes
villes où les habitants sont confinés
depuis près de dix semaines
alors ces villes se trouve en phase 0,5
il s'agit d'une étape intermédiaire où
les commerces de moins de 400 mètres
carrés ont pu ouvrir leurs portes sans
rendez vous mais attention le
confinement reste tout de même très
strictes les habitants ne peuvent pas
sortir de la ville ils peuvent se
promener ou faire du sport à seulement
moins d'un kilomètre de chez eux et un
couvre feu a été mis en place de 23h à
6h du matin la présence policière à être
renforcés pour veiller au respect de ces
mesures
beaucoup de madrilènes et de barcelonais
attendent impatiemment le passage en
face une qui pourrait être dès lundi